you
one wrong slip if you're not familiar
with this you're in trouble it's three
check the Lloyd tournament don't be too
quick to move your D pawns hmm all right
all right I'll take them now yeah I'll
go in for this oh they're pretty
vulnerable there King no just want to
open up this file for my rook get my
knight in there let him jump around is
their king scared hmm what are you doing
there huh Bishop here oh my goodness
that's one check I can't allow a third
check kidding me
yeah it's right in Queen here they only
need one more check their Queen gets
active I'm done you have 20 seconds okay
he needs to duck they're now moving um
guess I could go here don't get active
Queen
Wow yes I got second check and a
guaranteed third check oh my god oh okay
I I was playing - I don't know
- Hope Chest like in that one with the
bishop takes age - I don't know I
thought their opening was a bit passive
and I could get away with that but no I
shouldn't have done that okay
whoo gotta play this is a gambit really
bishop before I have to do this they're
not even testing it council I play e5
and then take on h7 okay now let's kick
them right now don't want to counsel too
early because there might be this stuff
where I can't get rid of the night oh
they're thinking about sacrificing here
and then Bishop here let's just castle
anyway in the end I guess I do have to
Castle and they are really going into
the think tank
all right burning a lot of gas I have
one check I could be throwing in there
less than 10 this one's not going to
finish less then three yep
they weren't quick enough on that one
all right so I have for a lot of us have
four six players with four I do see
Ferrari in there
yeah I saw Ferrari in there all right LM
chess boy so this is a I don't think
this is a rating that you could really
trust as a question mark I do like my
position though think Knights are really
really really good pieces okay they
don't have the bishop now what an
interesting game huh all right I want to
kill the night I'll definitely take the
knight yes now fear my knight he could
hit your king in many ways if it's a
knight versus Bishop ending I think my
opponents in trouble because the night
is dangerous man get that pawn back the
rook is a bit out of play now now they
could take here all right it's sort of
having
versus Bishop position careful King
don't get too crazy look at this game
all right
Oh Fork is it the rook that's a key move
hmm
I'm going to push and go here to stop a
check with the rook take twice here if
they push get behind better not come out
King oh I could have given a check keep
my King on a dark square hold her down
in time wow that one that one felt like
it was just regular chess did did either
of us even give a check
Oh bad hope chess masters on deck
they're playing hope chess master right
now no he nearly just got killed
that's how quick these games could end
fishing pole style right here is
definitely a good idea I think started
off pretty confident but alright now
we're cooking we got mates we got check
here and it's a guaranteed game over to
give a fourth check need be they are
resigning and there we go Ferraris up
top 16 okay is there a variant he isn't
good at sixteen twelve twelve eight
eight one thing is for sure he is going
to be fast
okay hmm let's see how he addresses this
stuff hmm no stay in put it take my
night
mmm he's nervous he's in the think tank
he's got a flat tire maybe ah
all right let's save the night I have a
check here mmm very nice all right I see
they could land a check but I have a
time edge who woulda thunk it
they didn't go straight in for that
mm-hmm I guess here um as far as I want
to go and we have a ten-second edge hmm
more checks any checks threatening a
check I just want to get a rock off oh
no um are you kidding me oh I got to do
that
oh they got that in
man I don't think I could have stopped
that no I don't think I could have
stopped that that rook activity was
enough ah I just wanted one rook off
just one and I had that like it was much
more clear to me if I get that one rook
of mmm man I had them thinking - okay
he's got 2016 pelvic I'm at 12 okay 94
let's get in there I had some good
pressure in that game really good
pressure
let's castle probably just throw the
knight in there yeah takes I have a
mountain to back to term and I had a
fourth even if I needed it with the pawn
takes Queen or I don't know what I'm
talking about that didn't make sense all
right we have 14 I must move as e6 there
and we're going to we're going to link
this Knight once again on g4 I like
seeing in early castles let's jump in
Knight f3 I take what's check so why
three four three it's so much more oh
let's go here and develop hang on to
that pond for the moment mmm okay I
really I don't know if I I'm playing
this so well
to babysit that pond
okay I'm okay with giving that pawn up
I'm thinking about h5 and then maybe
even if the knight moves something like
this queen h2 driven directly now you
take me less than eight seconds is
anything hmm
they don't have any time 24 oh man okay
I'm at 16 this is almost hour already a
loss now gets captured guaranteed loss
not quite
my queen is going to try though I only
need one more check Queen takes here's
the idea go here if the knight move
should have something like here this is
a threat I could also just okay that's
me there check back to term in 2028 is
it Ferrari is he playing right now he's
playing against LM chess boy 99 who
clearly is just playing for the first
time I won the first times in three
check he has a rating increase nearly
400 that was the game that went down
that was the game I played where there
were no checks I went right down to an
ending with no checks for either of us
Knight g4 ah now let's take this pawn
may be a bit questionable huh hmm take
twice here take my knight let's now
let's take like this so Bishop takes
pawn is in hitting with check 26 seconds
let's just run away um
threatening this can use to go to the
corner
that's three checks right there back to
tournament just like that
ooh and the Ferrari took a hit chess boy
got him I guess now they're playing
right now now okay that that game just
ended we are paired up again I got team
white this time playing the French kind
of went upon okay careful place this in
regular chess - hmm he's going to shut
it down he five now don't do that here
comes my knight sacrifice on d6 maybe f5
sacrifice on g7 I want Knight f5 Knight
takes g7 really bad I'm doing it
sacrificing a piece to get it in que no
que no style Bishop h6
let's just take Bishop h6 is pretty
deadly sneak my queen into h6
move my knight give mate let's take here
okay give some material back okay
guess we'll play regular chess like okay
this is good
Bishop takes pawn on the knight taking
here with check let's open up a file
towards their king
this is what they did against me how's
my king
let's talk him in and push this pawn
that rook out of there there's only two
checks that could give I'm on the rook I
got this definitely have this who they
timed out back to term at 28 were
knotted at 28 less than 13 minutes left
I have fire though hmm that's good news
56 players good turnout for this alloyed
tournament okay I'm bored and Joe
next opponent it's tough playing is
black it really is tough hmm interesting
decision I think I'm covering all that
good checks really well I'm going to
keep the Queen's on and know I would
have a check on this diagonal I
shouldn't have even played that should
just go King side castle no no reason to
complicate it
d5 next where's the Queen Gong she's
trapped just like in those puzzles Oh No
there's that five okay okay now we got
this
I only need a third check I got two in
there that's the third back to
tournament thirty-two thirty one twenty
six twenty four less than twelve okay
Captain Obvious on board one of the
tricky Knights all right let's see how
the defender got to do this move huh and
let's just open it up all right let's
drift over in this direction here all
right um not sure what that's doing okay
actually there's a square for my knight
now I want to sneak into these dark
squares they're light square Bishop
isn't playing h6 I'm just jumping in I'm
going here no matter what I might end up
mating on the dark squares just look for
sacs right here on either of these two
let's go for that one
King has to hide
huh now I could give checks like this
but I think I just want to recapture no
this is getting ripped apart now to give
my petrol check like regular chest stuff
that's how strong this position is and
yeah there's more checks
we got mate coming up and they resigned
back determined 36 34 I have a two-point
lead Ferrari kicked it into berserk mode
he's like I've had enough
he SOT was close and he put it into a
different gear he's back again back at
it again with the berserk okay uh yeah
okay I guess I'm gonna go up on grabbing
huh I guess so no keep that night right
in there yeah he's there to stay yeah
even if they threaten it with a pawn
oh maybe not well I'm on the night
that's nice hmm this was going to go
down to the wire to feel it yeah need to
connect rooks they could take this pawn
I could take wits check first very
important mm-hmm no that would be bad I
think here is correct
I want the Queen's off I gotta cover
this square yeah I take my bishop oh I
had a check I had meat I had me oh come
on Pandu something dangerous the rook
captures my night I'm gonna have good
stuff
I got me oh they don't have a check the
bishop doesn't have a check it's in the
wrong spot for that check back to
tournament they're down in time the
bishop was on f2 there was always the
threat to take on g7 and then give a
final check with the bishop before I
could get my King to a light square okay
we still have less than eight he just
finished I believe he has 42 we're gonna
get paired up this is the number one guy
yes oh my god
this is an intense tournament okay let's
jump right in
mmm oh they just took with that let's
get out of that let's check let's see
Bishop takes
no good because that file opens up I
just want to open this up no we have the
positions really opening up no need to
cover my light squares yes definitely
let's hit the Queen let's open up the
e-file
let's take here take here with check
might need to do a queen sac I got one
check in there mmm
I think I should be able to hold this my
knight coming in to e5 should be really
strong let's get out of queen takes rook
with check queen takes rook still who
could take here no um hmm oh man
is this working
oh I have a bishop check if Queen takes
it is working Queen here can't stop that
I got me Queen takes Knight there's
Bishop check here it is working out
let's check and that's me hole 1.3 4442
37 5 minutes 5 seconds 5 on the dot I
still have fire mmm
58 players in this one
who's next gotta get this one keep going
with the fire I don't see a king site
Viet owes so much feels like it's going
to be a long drawn-out game let's get
all my pieces working like to see their
LightSquared Bishop gone let's try that
um let's go here looking at some
sacrifices on f2 moving the Queen rook
instead the king rook is better if he's
ever captured it's not with check how
about we take here and then hear him on
the Queen he's a passed pawn these
Knights are dangerous around my king I
take my bishop their king is exposed and
they get a rook lift in their sacrifices
here now it's the winner material and
okay now we're just going to make sure I
could tuck my king away this is a good
spot
that way he could leave and do some
other stuff yeah this is going to be
let's keep it closed keep it closed and
now we're getting some checks in there's
a check another check and only need one
more tough to avoid the final check got
it back to tournament 48 44 43 minutes
in change four point lead he doesn't
have fire that's very good news dwarf
man let's go with the Sicilian Sicilian
Khan I believe is good for three check
ok
ah
I'm still going to go for this now the H
file definitely cannot open up bishop
takes here don't think is a good idea I
have night check here let's go for it
why not threatening a meeting - um-hmm
let's go here
look here I take if they try for a queen
trade that's not really good
oh oh boy
I want night here okay I think I have
this now the night is gonna help out
that's a check how many one more check
where is it where's the final check hmm
I don't see it Oh where's the final
check oh I gotta go here they're
threatening Queen takes here hmm I'm
running for my life five seconds I'm
dead oh yeah
I'm dead meat I'm cooked yeah I'm
getting mated forget about three checks
that's checkmate 4846 I have a two-point
lead and he now has fire hopefully his
game isn't going to end maybe I could
get paired up with them and always known
a fry my way to victory No
uh he could he could come back it's easy
to get a quick win in this variant um I
have no idea what's gonna happen no idea
please don't win hopefully I don't have
to win this one just end tournament 32
seconds oh he just went ahead he's got
50 I have 27 seconds to make some magic
happen and that's not gonna that's not a
good start maybe it is 20 seconds I
might have it oh I do have it 14 seconds
13 seconds I gotta come on come on come
on eight seconds don't know no fry me
don't notify me they resigned back to
tournament Oh 50 but they want to tie
breaks ah man so close ah 50 with fire
ah man
ah so close so close 60 players in that
one ah man that one game the bishop on
g3 hitting my queen yeah I think I am
busted I can't get that final check in
this game this one right here against
dwarf man
there wasn't a final check where's my
check I can't go here I ran out of fuel
hmm oh so close that's the guy no this
isn't the guy that ended up winning it
so close so close
fifty-fifty a tiebreaker all right let's
see everyone else
Pollux in there at tenth I see you guys
are telling me that it gets cut off and
we see as far as the number 9 guy there
is one just below page one two three
four five six that's going to do it all
right to the sixty of you that took part
in this created Lloyd tournament good
games all nice
you